[Applause]
thank you very much great to be back
haven't been for ages great to see
familiar faces and also don't forget to
thank your organizers they're doing lots
of work which is a often not seen I'm
just going to talk very quickly about a
little bit of code I wrote which may or
may not be useful to other people for
those who don't know me I used to be
around I moved out of London to Cornwall
that's the end of my village you have to
careful not to fall off into the sea
I run algorithmic art which meet in
London and coral I've started a dead
sounds choral group in Cornwall which is
growing slowly not many people there and
Curtin a joke or Molly sound for kids
and that's quite fun so the the kind of
the itch I wanted to scratch was I want
I use Python obviously I used notebooks
which are lovely they weren't around
when I started sound world and it's
great to visualize things in a notebook
but I wanted to visualize things that
are related like graphs sort of entities
that of relationships and the
traditional libraries like Mapple there
didn't seem to have any any answer I
wanted these graphs to be interactive so
that I couldn't zoom in or move things
around and I couldn't find anything
there's things like d3 but it didn't
immediately work in the notebook so it
said you couldn't find anything
something called Network X popped up on
my Google searches and it does you know
work with graph data and it does plot
charts including in a notebook but
they're static and they're not
particularly pretty and you can see that
if I have lots of data it's going to be
overwhelming and saturated so you don't
really understand what's really going on
and so I thought okay maybe I'll try
writing something myself what I wanted
to do was make it simple so easy things
simple other stuff optional this is
Network X again showing a graph output
up there and there's lots more code than
that's shown is shown on the screen
didn't want to do that I wanted to just
have a data frame like that
things related to the things you know
left-hand column right-hand column
maybe a way to show the strength of the
connection and I just wanted something
that just plot that data just just draw
lines between those entities and so
wrote something I'm I I'm not a
professional programmer but it's
actually quite easy and I think there's
only about 20 30 lines of code when I
say easy I wanted it to be as easy as
importing a module and then calling a
function passing it the dataframe
and for it to just just just plot the
damn thing sort of the language and it
is diseases that there's there's there's
a notebook showing import little
instruction there to create a date frame
I'm printing the data frame so you can
see how easy it is let me show you it in
action this is in inclu lab so it works
in Google as well not just a normal you
know can your locally installed you can
do a pip install and it works in code up
as well if you're if you're using that
import the library and plot it there you
go
and you can grab these things and move
them around if I can get my pointer to
work we I've got a slightly more
interesting example here where I'm
looking at a corpus of text recipes are
so artificially constructed and I'm just
building a pandas dataframe showing the
co-occurrence of words and you can you
can see more easily which words are
connected you know if I double click on
something hopefully they'll move the
centre so what I really wanted to say is
this is there it was quite easy to do a
notebook is sort of a web page you run
Python Python itself can construct HTML
and you can render HTML including
JavaScript in an output cell so once you
understand that it's not too difficult
there are a few options you know it
wasn't us you know there is a simple
path but you can do things like
change the length of the other lengths
and increase the size of modes and so on
if your data's sparse or if you've got
lots of it so I just want you to make
you aware of that I'm not aware of any
other tools that work as easily that in
in the notebook if you find it useful if
you don't find it useful let me know and
maybe we can improve it thank you very
much
[Applause]